in today's eye on money senior citizens
are getting creative to make ends meet
financially many are getting roommates
more than 33% of Americans over the age
of 65 and over do not have any money
save for retirement that's not good in
2016 seventy percent more seniors live
with roommates than a decade before CBS
News business analyst Jill Schlesinger
met two strangers who took a cue from
the Golden Girls they moved in together
in New York to save money living with
roommates if you want to live here I
don't want to see you I don't want to
hear you I don't want to smell you
cooking it's not just for the Golden
Girls
we sure save a lot of money just ask
Paul Covington since retiring about six
years ago
he's relied exclusively on Social
Security without any savings the 81 year
old needed help paying his mortgage so
Jim English a perfect stranger moved in
we signed an agreement so this was more
of a formal process which I liked a lot
Covington and English were matched
through the New York foundation for
senior citizens a nonprofit organization
that facilitates living arrangements for
seniors in need what were you nervous
about at the time pay my mortgage and
I'm paying less than what I would if I
was on my own by at least a few hundred
after five months of English
contributing to the mortgage and
utilities Covington was able to save
three thousand dollars with the money
coming in do you feel more comfortable
it's like step into heaven really in
terms of being relieved of economic
pressure having tynin English say the
benefits go beyond their bank accounts I
think people should be more in contact
and something like this I think would
work for a lot of people so I would
recommend it strongly my daughter and my
other two sons very excited for me that
I've got a roommate and that I'm under
supervision supervision this is a very
good idea Jill Schlesinger who joins us
at the table so it was it always for
same-sex people it's not
they're not trying to be romantic really
no this is not a dating service
yeah simply living arrangements exactly
and I think it's really interesting
because we saw in those stats a lot of
people having a hard time in retirement
if you are considering something like
this what's really important to remember
is that seniors are also targets for
scammers so unless you're working with
an organization you gotta have your
guard up a little bit right so think you
don't have an organization in your town
kind of get your get-get steeled you
want to do a little bit of a background
check you want to have a contract or a
lease but if possible certainly use an
organization they can match you where
they're there there are rules and what's
interesting is there are boundaries now
of course you make those boundaries once
you find out who the other person is but
for example for these two men they don't
want to have meals together they want to
live together they want to be respectful
of one another but they go their own way
when it comes to their meals how
involved should family members get in
something like this in this case the
owner's son actually found the
organization he said you know my father
was struggling and he was quite a hard
time paying the mortgage as you heard
and you know when you talk to them now
they talk about how the families love
each other it was almost as if they were
bringing someone new into the family and
really was so it's sort of like
energizing to be around both of them who
seemed to be in a happier place so the
idea of a roommate in older age
terrifies you what can you do now to
make sure it doesn't happen you know
there are a lot of people who are not
ready to face your kids like two
different people to consider like if
you're in your 30s 40s 50s and realized
you're not gonna make it for retirement
you want to save more but if you are
later in life it's hard to make up
ground just by going through your budget
so if you realize there's a big problem
I think you have a conversation with
your kids or any relatives you are
honest you reveal everything then you
can come up with a game plan maybe it's
a co-living arrangement with your family
maybe it's with somebody else one of
these organizations maybe maybe it could
be a reverse mortgage if you own
property but you've got to be very
careful with these products they are
complex
did you need another opinion get a
financial adviser involved you get an
estate planning attorney involved you
get people talking that is the best
quality and Jim have a contingency plan
in case things don't go well there's
actually a contract and there is a
30-day out for each side so they can
give 30 days notice now what's
interesting is let's say that they stay
together for years now it's been months
right but let's say this really does
work
maybe I asked them would you consider
maybe making different arrangements for
example if the owner of the property
dies what happens to this person is that
get did he get evicted after 30 days
should there be an attorney who says
look we're gonna give them three months
or six months to get out if the death
occurs these are the kinds of things
that you can talk about
I love the arrangement because I
actually think it also really does fuel
both of them both of them they feel like
they are happier together maybe living
alone and it does address some of the
loneliness issues look both of them have
family that live nearby but they say
that this arrangement it's so nice to
come home to somebody they joke about
supervision but it is nice you've got
somebody kind of looking out for you
yeah both ways I would like that if you
could do it with a male platonic friend
if the time comes I would much rather
have a male roommate as dirty but I just
like the different dynamic we just think
differently I that would be my friend
you don't know you could live with me I
can be I could take care of you I'm a
baby we may be really good all right Joe
thank you
you